in the ever revolving landscape of the
digital realm where visibility is
Paramount and competition is FS
Mastering the Art and Science of search
Eng and optimization SEO has never been
more crucial as we set our sides on 2024
the world of SEO is posed for remarkable
Transformations offering a spectrum of
opportunities to those who Dare To Tread
its Dynamic path imagine having the
power to harness the algorithms that
decide which website rise to the top of
search engine results and we the ability
to craft compelling content that not
only captures the hearts and minds of
your audience but also climbs the
digital ranks effortlessly picture
yourself as the guiding force behind
businesses striving for online
prominence in this SEO road map for 2024
we will navigate through the twist and
turns of the SEO landscape unveiling the
strategies and insights that will make
you a true Su expert in the year ahead
from understanding the latest trends and
staying ahead of algorithm updates to
perfecting the intricate dance of
technical SEO and content strategy this
road map will be your companion on the
journey to SEO Mastery so fasten your
seat belts as you embark on a training
Expedition into the world of SEO in 2024
it's time to unlock the secrets of
search engines and Propel yourself into
the realm of digital success and before
starting if you are interested in
advancing your career and considering
puru University's postgraduate program
in digital marketing this comprehensive
program offers certification as a
digital marketer and as expert through
live Interactive Learning dive deep into
fundamental and advanced digital
marketing strategies utilizing Howard
business publishing cases Stant
simulations and Hands-On participation
in 20 plus projects access the full
spectrum of digital marketing tools like
chat GPD and AI tools complemented by 35
Plus dedicated resources and now we'll
see the current SEO trends that are
prevailing so the number one is user
experience user experience is a top
priority in SEO search engines now
consider factors like page speed mobile
friendliness and user friendly layouts
as crucial for ranking well positive
user experience keeps visitors on your
site and reduces bounce rates and the
next is mobile optimization mobile
optimization remains a key challenge
with the increasing use of smartphones
ensuring that your website is mobile
friendly is vital for SEO success this
includes responsive design fast loading
times and mobile first indexing and now
moving to the next Trend that is eat
expertise authoritativeness and
trustworthiness eat is critical for SEO
in 2023 search engines aims to provide
users with high quality and trustworthy
content demonstrating expertise
authoritativeness and trustworthiness in
your content and across your site is
essential and the next trend is voice
search voice search continues to grow
optimizing for voice search involves
using natural language answering
specific questions and providing concise
informative content understanding how
users speak their queries is key and now
moving on to the next Trend that is
content quality and relevance high
quality relevant content is essential
creating content that addresses user
intent is up to date and adds value to
your audience is crucial for SE success
and the next trend is data analytics and
AI data analytics and AI tools are
increasingly used for SEO leveraging
data driven insights Nai technology
helps in making informed decisions
personalizing content and improvising
user experiences these Trends and
challenges highlight the importance of
adapting to the challenging landscape of
SEO to maintain and improve your website
search engine rankings and visibility
now we'll start with the SEO expert road
map for
2024 so so the first step is mastering
the basics that is on page and off page
SEO so we'll start with on page SEO and
the first keyword or the first features
of on page SEO is that is keyword
research understand how to perform
keyword research to identify relevant
Search terms for your content and then
comes the content optimization learn how
to optimize your web pages with high
quality relevant content and
strategically place keywords within it
and then comes the metat Tex familiarize
yourself with optimizing meta tags
including title tags meta descriptions
and header tags and then comes the URL
structure understand the importance of a
clean and SEO friendly URL structure and
then there is internal linking know how
to create an effective internal linking
structure to enhance user experience and
SEO and now coming to oage SEO we'll see
the features of it number one is
backlink building that is learn how to
build highquality backlinks from
authoritative websites in your niche
understand the importance of natural
earned backlinks for off page SE then
comes the social signals comprehend the
role of social media in off page SEO and
how social signals can impact sege
engine rankings and then comes the local
SEO for businesses targeting a local
audience Master local SEO strategies
including claiming your Google my
business listing and managing online
reviews and then comes the citation
building understand the significance of
nap name address phone number
consistency for local SEO and citation
building and the next is brand manions
know how unlink brand manions can
contribute to offage SEO and reputation
management by mastering these on page
and off page SEO Basics you will build a
solid foundation for the journey to
become an SEO expert and now moving on
to the next step that is stay informed
on SEO Trends so continuously follow
industry blogs webinars and conferences
to keep up with SEO trends and algorithm
updates so now you'll see the steps how
you can achieve this step so the number
one is subscribe to SEO blogs that is
follow reputable SEO blogs and websites
like Moos search engine land and search
engine journal to get the latest updates
and insights in the field the second is
join SEO communities participate in
online SEO communities and forums like
reddits SEO or SEO related groups on
LinkedIn to discuss Trends and learn
from others in the industry
and now moving on to the next that is
webinars and conferences attend SE
webinars and conferences where industry
experts discuss new trends best
practices and algorithm updates keep an
eye out for both local and international
events now coming to the next that is
SEO newsletters subscribe to SEO
newsletters that provide regular updates
on industry news and Trends these
newsletters often curate valuable
information now coming to the next that
is podcast listen to S po podcast where
experts share their knowledge and
insights podcast are a convenient way to
stay informed on the go so this was all
about the Second Step that is stay
informed on SEO Trends now moving on to
the next step that is technical SEO
proficiency so now we'll see the steps
how we can master in this technical SEO
proficiency and the number one is s
speed optimization ensure your website
loads quickly to improve user experience
and search engine rankings compress
images Minify CSS and JavaScript and
leverage browser caching and the next is
mobile friendliness optimize your site
for mobile users as Google prioritizes
mobile first indexing use responsive
design Test Mobile usability and create
mobile friendly content and the next is
schema markup Implement schema markup to
provide search engines with structured
data about your content this can enhance
Rich Snippets in search results and
improve click through rates and the next
next is cability and indexability ensure
that search engines can easily CW and
index your websites use a sitemap
robots. txe and canonical tags to guide
search engines effectively and the next
is structure data Implement structure
data to help search engines understand
the content on your site better now
moving to the next step that is step
four that is content strategy and now
we'll see the features or the steps to
learn content strategy number one is
keyword research and targeting start
with Comprehensive keyword research to
identify relevant keywords and phrases
that your audience is searching for the
next is quality and relevance ensure
your content is of high quality
informative and relevant to your target
audience then comes the content variety
diversify your content types including
blog post videos infographics and
podcast then comes the topic clusters
and pillar content Implement a topic
cluster strategy where you create pillar
content that is comprehensive guides or
Cornerstone articles and supported with
related in-depth articles and then comes
the content promotion develop a plan to
promote your content through social
media email marketing and Outreach so
this was about the fourth step now
coming to the fifth step that is eat and
user experience so eat that is expertise
authoritativeness and
trustworthiness so the first step to
learn all these is focus on
demonstrating expertise in your content
by showcasing your qualifications and
expertise in the subject matter
establish authoritativeness by earning
backlinks from reputable sources and
ensure your content is trustworthy and
well referenced and the next is user
centering content craft content that
genuinely serves the users's need
offering valuable information and
solutions and then is transparent
attribution clearly attribute authors
and their credentials for the content
reinforcing trust and Authority and then
is the mobile friendly user experience
ensure your website is mobile responsive
as Google values a positive mobile user
experience and then comes the user
engagement metrix monitor user
engagement metrics like click through
rates bounce rates and time on site now
moving on to the next step that is data
analysis and tools so now we'll see the
steps to learn data analysis and tools
that is the first step is Google
analytics Mastery learn how to set up
and effectively use Google analytics to
track website performance user behavior
and conversion metrics then comes the
Google search console proficiency that
is understand the insights and tools
available in Google search console to
monitor website visibility in search
results identify issues and optimize
content and then comes the keyword
research tools familiarize yourself with
keyword research tools such as seam Rush
SCM Rush RFS and most to identify
valuable keywords and assess keyword
competition and and then comes the SEO
auditing software utilize SEO auditing
tools like screaming frog or side bulb
to conduct comprehensive website audits
identify technical SEO issues and
optimize sze structure and then comes
the data visualization skills develop
the ability to create visual reports and
dashboards to communicate SEO
performance data effectively to
stakeholders or clients and now moving
on to the seventh step that is link
building strategies and now we'll see
the steps for this step that is quality
or quality that is focus on acquiring
high quality authoritative back from
reputable websites rather than pursuing
a large volume of low quality links the
next is natural link acquisition and
then comes the Outreach and relationship
building that is actively reach out to
relevant websites bloggers and
influencers to request back links and
then is the guest posting that is
contribute guest post to authoritative
websites in your Niche Ure that the
content is valuable and relevant and
then comes the Monitor and ISO regularly
monitor your backlink profile to
identify and ISO any toxic or spammy
links that could harm your Su efforts so
this was all about the seventh step now
moving on to the next step that is
eighth algorithm changes so now we'll
see the steps what the algorithm changes
include so the number one is stay
informed that is regularly monitor SEO
news sources and official search engine
announcements to stay up to date of any
upcoming algorithm changes the next is
adapt quickly when algorithm updates
occur be prepared to adjust your ASO
strategies promptly to align with the
new ranking criteria and requirements
the next is analyze impact and then
comes the audit and optimize that is
conduct regular site audits to identify
and address any issues that might affect
your website's ranking then comes the
diversify strategies avoid over Reliance
on specific SEO tactics now coming to to
the ninth step that is structured SEO
strategy now moving to the steps that
include the structured SE strategy the
number one is keyword research and
targeting and then comes the content
planning that is create a Content
calendar that outlines when and what
type of content you will produce and
then comes the on page optimization that
is Implement on page SEO techniques
including optimizing metax and then
comes the link building strategy that is
develop a strategy for acquiring high
quality back
and then comes the performance
monitoring that is regularly track the
performance of your Su efforts using
tools like Google analytics and then
comes the next step that is the 10th
step that is certifications and
courses now we'll see the steps the
number one is choose reputable Su
certification programs op for well
recognized and reputable certification
programs such as Google analytics or
Google ad certification these
certifications demonstrate your
expertise in specific SEO areas and then
comes the advanced SEO courses consider
enrolling in advanced SEO courses
offered by trusted educational
institutions such as universities or
online learning platforms such as simply
learn that have postgraduate program for
digital marketing now moving on to the
third step that is specialized SE
certification look for specialized SEO
certification from organizations like Mo
or Hub Sport and then comes stay updated
the your field evolves rapidly so you
have to stay updated as this is crucial
for long-term success and then comes the
practical application seek out courses
that include Hands-On projects and
practical exercises by investing in
certifications and courses that align
with your career goals and staying
committed to continuous learning you
will be well on your way to becoming a
proficient Su expert now moving to the
next step that is 11th step that is
practice and experiment and now we'll
see the steps in this step that is a AB
testing that is conduct AB test to
compare different elements of your
website such as headlines images or
calls to action to determine what
resonate best with your audience and
improves SE results then comes the
keyword experimentation and that is
continuously test and refine your
keyword strategies explore new keywords
and then comes the content iteration
that is regularly update and improve
existing content based on user feedback
and analytics data and then comes the
link building strategies experiment with
various link building techniques
Outreach methods and content promotion
strategies to identify what works best
for Niche and audience and then comes
local SEO tactics experiment with
different local SEO techniques such as
optimizing Google my business profiles
soliciting reviews and running localized
ad campaigns to enhance your local
search visibility experimentation is a
critical expect of su expertise as it
allows you to fine-tune your strategies
Based on data and feedback ultimately
driving better results and now these are
the steps to be owner Su expert and for
the SEO road map 2024 now moving to the
job roles within the field of SEO so
there are various job roles within the
field of SEO each with its own set of
responsibilities and expertise here are
some common SEO job roles and we'll
start with SEO specialist SEO
Specialists are experts in optimizing
websites for search engines they focus
on on page and off-page SC optic
optimization keyword research and
implementing SEO best practices and the
average base salary for SEO specialist
in United States is
$150,000 per year and in India it is 11
lakhs perom and now coming to the next
job roll that is content strategist
content strategists are responsible for
planning and creating content that
aligns with SEO goals they develop
content strategies conduct keyword
research and ensure content is optimized
for search engines and their average
salary in United States is
$145,000 perom and in India it is 13
lakhs perom and then comes the technical
Su manager that is focus on the
technical aspects of a website such as
site structure page speed and mobile
optimization they work to improve the
website's technical performance for
better search rankings and the average
salary for technical SE manager in
United States is
$120,000 and in India it is 10 lakhs
perom and now moving to link building
specialist link building specialist
concentrate on acquiring high quality
backlinks from authoritative websites
they play a crucial role in improving a
website's domain Authority and search
engine rankings and the average salary
for link building specialist in United
States is
$156,000 perom and then in India it is 8
lakhs perom and then moving to the local
SEO specialist that is local SEO
specialist focus on optimizing a website
for local search results they help
businesses appear in local searches
particularly important for Brick and
Mortar businesses and the average salary
in United States for local SEO
specialist is $15,000 perom and in India
that is 7 lakhs perom so these roles SC
to various aspects of SEO from content
creation and Technical optimizations to
local search and data analysis depending
on your interest and expertise you can
choose the role that best aligns with
your career goals in the field of su so
there you have it the SEO road map for
2024 SEO is a dynamic field and staying
ahead of the curve is key to your online
success make sure to stay tuned for more
in-depth videos on each of these topics
in the upcoming weeks and if you found
this video helpful don't forget to hit
that like button subscribe to our
Channel and ring the notification Bell
so you never miss any update and please
share your thoughts in the comment
section below what other SEO topics do
you want to cover in the future thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here